the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
all right so those are all really great
presentations
you guys I'm excited about all the
projects you learned about and things
you accomplished so now as I mentioned
at the beginning what we're gonna do is
very quickly go through the design
process and then talk about the entire
remainder of the class and part of that
will be you guys down selecting from the
project's you've just discussed to the
top few that you think are good
candidates and then tonight everyone in
the class will let me know in a survey
what you want to actually work on and
then you'll be assigned into your final
project groups on Friday so last year
some teams wanted to work with the same
community partner or all wanted to work
together and other teams wanted to do
something different so there's
opportunity for change or not change
depending on what you want
so basically doing design and the design
process is challenging for some pretty
standard reasons of you have these
really severe trade-offs between you
know you want a material something
that's really light but really strong
etc it can be a very dynamic process
there's a lot of things happening at
once there's a lot of details to worry
about
there's always time pressure and there's
always economic pressure and that's even
more true when you're doing design for
developing countries so you need to know
your user and understand the need which
hopefully you've just addressed in your
trip but it's of course in a week you're
not gonna truly fully understand
everything there can be ethical concerns
that come up that are more severe than
they are at a typical corporate design
issue and there's some pretty extreme
design constraints in terms of the costs
and the robustness and is it usable can
you manufacture and distribute it and
then also transparency is it easy to fix
do people really understand how it works
can be even more important but it's all
super rewarding too so it's worth doing
and so there's a lot of different ways
that people consider the design process
so this is one way of looking at it so
first you gather information what you
just did hypothetically and defined the
problem which you are doing or just did
and then you create design
specifications what you're doing this
week generating ideas evaluating your
concepts doing some sort of analysis and
experimentation to really learn what
you're doing doing detail design to get
it work out all the details fabricating
testing and evaluation so that's one way
to think about it another way is to
think about it from more of a stage
standpoint so you start with your
planning and then you get mission
approval so thinking about it that way
Friday is mission approval and then you
do your concept development and you have
a concept review system level design
with a another review detail design
another review testing and refinement
and then you're approved for production
and can hypothetically do production ooh
there are some crazy controls here that
I did not put in but clearly came up so
I tried to just map how these two
approaches work and how they connect and
of course there's actually other ways of
describing the design process and these
all interlink and I'm not going into
these in a lot of detail but we're sort
of gonna just go through this in the
class if you haven't seen it already but
another one to look about look at is
your functional requirements so what
does design have to do and then how is
the design gonna meet the requirement
analyzing any decisions and figuring out
what you're doing doing the research to
make sure you're not building a better
mousetrap when there's plenty of good
ones out there the risk what's gonna
happen if things don't work out and then
your countermeasures what if things
don't work what do you do and this is
from Alex Slocum and he likes to use
language and I don't always use
this is from David Wallace is another
design profession of mechanical
engineering so all of these met methods
I've talked about all seem relatively
linear which is a lie so one way that
David likes to show is that you're
always considering your economic your
physics and your analysis but you start
out with very a lot of brats and very
little depth and then as you go from
idea to concept a detail you get much
more depth and much less breadth but
you're always sort of cycling through
all of the steps so similarly this is
another way of looking at it so you
right now we're gonna be doing pew
charts to figure out your I'd projects
and then once you figure out your
projects you're gonna do more project
features to figure out what your
implementation is and then when you
figure that out
you're gonna get all the way down to
like figuring out am I gonna use a screw
or a nut or I mean a screw or a bolt
with a knot to connect these things like
a wood screw or not in bolt and so each
time you're winnowing down and so you're
repeating a lot of the same things
you're gonna have to go back and do
research it's not like you get to do
research once at the beginning of the
class and you never have to investigate
anything again it's just a level of
depth versus breadth that you're
considering I talked about this a little
bit previously on the charcoal project
and how the press evolved but I just
wanted to emphasize that our class is
getting to like and hopefully getting to
a really good prototype and sometimes
students have in mind like that's the
end process and that's not the best way
to think about things if you think about
say an iPod
it started out ten years ago with one
iteration and that was you know a
production product that had have many
prototypes ahead of itself and now if
you think 10 years later not only does
the iPod itself look really different
but there's also all these other
implementations of the iPod that are out
there and many many devices along the
way to get there so that's just a true
and ITA's iPod is an obviously complex
example but something even as simple as
a Netflix envelope in seven years has
gone through a ridiculous number of
design changes and improvements so it's
just a reality of a design
that you're always getting to the next
to a good stage hopefully but you're not
ever getting to you know you can't think
that your first prototyping the orange
juice bag sealer is a great example you
delivered it it made sense a year ago
for being checked to twelve volt battery
and now you can't find any and it has a
different need and there's other needs
coming up so there's always going to be
optimizations okay so I want to go over
a few chart today because that's what
you're gonna be using if you haven't
seen it whew with a guy who came up with
this method and so it's just a way of
comparing different ideas it seems in
some ways that you do it it seems like
it can be kind of quantum to
quantitative and it's absolutely not as
an entirely qualitative method and using
it quantitatively is sort of defeating
the purpose of it so what he the way you
use it is you have a bunch of criteria
on your left vertical access and then a
bunch of options that you compare I
always pick the bad right a little
better and so today we're just going to
compare a nail to a a ring shank now to
a staple and a screw so when you're
doing a few chart usually doing it in a
group and so it's a good idea to make
sure that everyone knows what each of
these options are so it can be helpful
to draw like a really fast simple
diagram just so that everyone you're
sure has in mind what the differences
are so if you don't know a ring shank
nail is somewhere between a screw and a
nail and that it has little rings on the
edge so that it helps prevent the nail
from popping back out once you drive it
in but you still drive it in like and
now as opposed to screwing it in like a
screw
and then a staple obviously so it's nice
to have a drawing as well and then you
need some criteria for how you're going
to compare all of these options and so
you just go through what you think are
the most important ones there are more
complicated charts that sort of are
versions of few charts where you can put
different weighting on your different
criteria that gets really hard to do
especially as you have more criteria
like how much more important is holding
than effort like it gets a little
complicated to figure that out so
sometimes because this is so qualitative
just having these out there and then
keeping in mind your mental weightings
is sufficient and so then you want one
of your items to be your standard so
this is really important that you just
pick one that you think might be the
most standard and just give it an ass
for standard or 0 or whatever whatever
you want to use
it's tempting not to give a standard
right because it's kind of annoying like
it might mean that on some like that if
the nail is the cheapest option then
your standard everything else is going
to be more expensive everything else is
going to be off the chart so it's not
actually in the middle which is what you
want however you always need to compare
to something if you're just there's
because there's no like neutral so you
have to define your neutral so this is
the way they do that so it's tempting to
not define a neutral
it makes the future a whole lot more
useful if you do and then you can just
go through and grade them so a ring
shank compare in terms of rate and some
people like to go down some people like
to go across that's sort of whatever you
prefer but so a ring shank is about the
same speed a staple is faster a screw is
probably slower so that's just how you
do it for a cost a ring shank is going
to be more expensive and that's another
confusing thing like more expensive
seems like it to be a plus but it's
actually a minus right because that's
worse a staple will be cheaper and a
screw is going to be more expensive for
holding
ring shank is a little better staples a
little worse the screw is a whole lot
better so you can do minuses and pluses
you can do ones and twos if you do ones
and twos again this is qualitative so no
adding those numbers at the end and for
effort a shank a similar staple is
probably easier and thus harder so yeah
so as I said a lot of people are then
tempted to put a line at the bottom and
be like alright this is a 0 this is a 0
this is which is not the way to use app
you charge so don't ever do this and the
reason is that again there's different
qualities for different weightings for
all of these things so that adding these
up isn't that meaningful and isn't a
good way to make a decision but it does
very quickly help you determine you know
just looking what are the pros and cons
of each one in a visual way that's
pretty fast so really think about the
pros and cons and make sure you're
actually considering the pros and cons
that are important to you and then
finally if we didn't have the ring shank
here and you saw the nail and the screw
the pew chart is something that might
lead you to develop the ring shank where
you're like ok the screw is slower and
the cost is worse and effort is worse
but holding is really good what could I
do that would combine my screw with my
nail to get me a better product and that
would might lead you to develop the ring
shank now so that's one nice way to use
the future artists to sort of combine
projects or concepts and help you do
that in a way that works well there any
questions about the future because
you're going to use it in 10 minutes ok
and this is just there it is another
tool that's common that you might want
to use is when you're developing a
schedule people often use something
called a Gantt chart and I know you
can't read most of what's on here but
basically you have your list of tasks
how long they're gonna take and then you
sort of spread them out and the thing
that's important or helpful about a
Gantt chart is listing the tasks that
rely on each other so if one of your
tasks is say you're doing that rice
husking and you need a mill and you
hadn't bought that mill you'd have to
order a mill and have to be here and you
can't do any testing with your mill
until it gets here and so that's on the
critical path because you need to do the
testing and therefore that means you
need to order it yesterday oh and it's a
good thing you bought it so so that's
really help this is a helpful way to
think about your schedule it's not a
requirement in this class that use a
Gantt chart so I'm not going to talk
about it anymore but you can google it
and find lots of different tools but
it's just one way of building your
schedule that works pretty well so some
of the best practices for doing the
design process or one to have people
assigned to different roles so some
roles that work really well are someone
who's in charge of your timeline so are
you hitting those dates that you outline
on your schedule and regardless what can
we do right now so if you're waiting for
that mill to arrive or whatever you've
ordered to arrive you can be really
tempting to be like oh there's nothing
to do today it'll be here on Friday and
I won't do anything until then and
that's really dangerous because time is
so tight and so figuring out what can we
do right now even if it's not on the
critical path just to make sure we're
moving forward and then having someone
else who's making sure that what you're
doing is actually related to your goal
because it can be easy to get really
involved and figuring out the perfect
pieceof and doing an adhesive analysis
when your goal is just to have a good
enough adhesive and you should use the
first one you found and go with it or
whatever and then having someone who's
the key person on your team who's in
charge of communicating with your
community partner for this class I'm
going to ask that you try to communicate
with partner once a week some of you may
have a hard time doing that but you
should at least be trying to communicate
once a week so that you're getting
regular feedback and then finally
documentation making sure that you're
documenting what you do well which will
you really thank yourselves for the end
of the class when you have to write a
final report as it
the more documentation you do ahead of
time the easier that'll be and then
general recommendations are failing fast
this one and so it's much better to
figure out that your idea doesn't work
today than it is the day before your
presentation right and so the sooner you
can be developing stuff so that you can
figure out this failures and fixing them
the better and so along those lines
prototyping early and often and then
finally identifying any of your
deal-breakers immediately so any
physical and possibilities or things
that are just not going to work figuring
those out as soon as possible so that
you don't get into failing spectacularly
but only filling in small areas that you
can recover from I don't know why these
slides are like this I'm sorry guys I
should have run through it ahead of time
I didn't think it would be in there
anyway so I picked one of the design
processes to sort of run us through what
we're doing and we're basically doing
each stage of the design process in a
week which is ridiculously fast but it's
why the pressure is on automatically
right from today because this is all the
time we have your final presentation is
on May 7th which is a Saturday it's in
your syllabus so if you aren't free on
that day you should talk to me real soon
but we're doing them as a group with
other d-lab classes and so that's six
weeks total is what we have and so
everything we're doing is you know it's
basically we have a week for each stage
which is very rapid and that really
drives what your project should be so as
you as you probably noticed when I
showed last year's project none of them
were inventing a brand new washing
machine say it was making us very small
incremental improvement on something and
that's what you want to do because it's
much better to have a really awesome
small incremental improvement that'll
actually help your organization and be a
benefit than to make very small progress
on a really big project that's not going
to help anyone because you haven't
completed it by the end of the day so
I've revised I've created like a part
two syllabus which I'll hand out as soon
as I pick them up from the copier but
basically
it has what we're doing each day and
then the assignments do and then below
this the schedule is a bunch of details
about each assignment so hopefully
everything will be super clear but
things to know is that there's a lot of
time that's unscheduled where I'm not
gonna be lecturing at all I mean it's
not gonna be lecturing at all it's just
time for your team to work that doesn't
mean you should blow off class we're
still checking attendance we still
expect you to be here the work time is
pretty valuable I meet and I will be
stopping by each team every session at
least once to check in on how you're
doing your mentors will be stopping by
almost every session to check in and
help you so it's a good time to work
where you know your team members are
available where it's out of class time
it's harder to get everyone together in
a group and so along those lines if
you're not going to be working in this
classroom your team should leave a note
where you are so that as a meet and I
are doing our rounds we can find you so
again we actually do expect you to be
here and then second is you're gonna be
creating a wiki page the there's a wiki
link off of the stellar website and so
each team should have a wiki page where
you can document your design process so
rather than having physical design
notebooks which get really challenging
in terms of you want them with you at
all times I need to take them to grade
you grade them D lab has started doing
wiki's so that we can do grading without
stealing your design notebooks and stuff
like that that's where you should
document everything and it's also useful
for club future classes they get to see
everything that you're worked on so that
can be helpful and then there will be a
design review on April 22nd where you'll
have ten minutes to present your project
and we'll have people from outside the
class coming and give feedback and there
you'll want to have a prototype and I'll
talk more about that as it gets closer
and then the final presentations where
you'll it's sort of this combo where
you're both doing a public presentation
that'll be one minute along with like a
poster session that's what you're used
to if you've done previous d-lab classes
in the spring and then also doing a more
formal design review where you'll leave
the poster session and have a formal
design review in a separate room as well
we should do this separately and we're
trying to combine them just for
efficiency sake and then finally I have
a final report which
is written up well here and then I'll go
through more as we get closer so what
are we doing now you guys need to
finalize what your actual projects are
going to be and so what I'd like you to
do is sort of come up with your top and
projects hopefully at least three and
less than they're no more than six I
would say it would be a good range and
do a few chart with them so that you can
come up with the best figure out what
projects are worth working on and you
should come up with like one or two or
the ones that you recommend going ahead
with and then at 2:30 which Wow I'd be
able to do micro presentations because
things went long
so probably we'll just have you do the
just by the end of class you need to
hand in to me what are your top couple
projects with a little description that
you can email me so that every everyone
can know what they're working on but
hopefully you're not too far afield from
what you just presented so people have a
general idea of what you're working on
so before you I let you go I just want
to do one last thing which is what few
criteria we should be using because you
can have some variation do you think we
should use yeah so your
budget is about $500 so you definitely
don't want to be do inventing anything
that's gonna require $50,000 what else
yes but you have six weeks so you're
unlikely to get funding for in these six
weeks they're like if it's $700 you know
let's talk about what you actually need
but most teams had budget leftover last
year when they had $500 so I don't think
this is a super high constraint it just
gives you an order of magnitude yeah so
what else
yep so I think a bigger like general one
is like do you mean like locally yeah
so then like I said though that would
probably be something more specific for
different examples or different projects
like if you have like 12 ideas for your
rice Husker but I think for here like
one that's along those lines is just
does it help your community
and we embedded in that is if they can't
build it it's not gonna help them right
so but we're looking at very broad
strokes at this level any others yeah so
so si se puede right we want to be able
to say that so that's pretty important
to be able to say yes we can my son is
really into Bob the Builder and that's
all I hear is can we build it yes we can
and then one other that's important to
me is that is relevant to the energy
class which I think they all are but
like a water project might be really
compelling it's not relevant to energy
so you want to make sure that it does
actually fit within the boundaries of
class but they're pretty broadly defined
so these are the four that I really want
to make sure you include that you might
want to add others as well but every
team should include these are there any
questions so I'm going to grab the
syllabus the revised syllabi and the
project description and the big paper
that you can use to make a few charts on
and that's what you should you should be
doing and by the end of class you need
to have top projects so great